- So have you all met before?
- Yeah.
- We have.
- Okay.
- I've dressed Juliana a couple times.
- (crosstalk)
- You know
- Y'all are all dancers too,
I found this out about you.
- (laughter)
- No I am not like them,
I don't swing around.
- (crosstalk)
- Is it ballet, you studied ballet, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
Me an my sister.
My sister went to Kirov,
she was a real dancer.
I was a fake dancer but I pretend.
(laughter)
- I think all dancers are dancers.
- I like tulle and tight.
- Tulle and tight.
(laughter)
I love you.
All right your phone, I know,
'cause I talk to my stylist
all the time 'cause you
dressed me several times so.
I know that your phone blows
up at every award season.
Do you ever have to say no
'cause of time or any reason?
- Yeah it's time, that's all it is.
Those moments where it's
like the night before
and they're like, "I need a
custom dress for this tomorrow.
- And you were like, "I
left my wand at Hogwarts.
- And I'm like, okay.
And every now and then I'll do it.
I will.
I think we did a dress
for Ariana in four hours.
- Wow.
- And it was amazing and short.
- You know what though,
to dress that body, yes.
- Yeah, you know like...
- She is so beautiful.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Wow.
- So it just depends.
- Wow, alright.
You're just so busy, and
I'm always seeing everybody
on the carpet and I'm
like, "Oh, I'm in Ceriona.
They're like, "Me too.
I'm like, :"Okay.
You make me feel cool
'cause I'm never that girl.
- You always look good.
- Outside of that situation,
because of you and my stylist.
(applause)
- Oh my God, what up, yeah.
(crosstalk)
- That's my Meryl dress.
- Yes your Meryl dress.
- You made the dress for me
that I met Meryl Streep in.
- Yeah.
(crosstalk)
And I like this because
this is a little different,
it still you're kinda
cool edgy rock moment.
But a little more glamorous,
it's for the Golden Globe.
- It was my first time ever
to go to anything like that.
Everyone always thinks
I go to music things.
- Yeah.
So I was so out of place.
- It was amazing.
You looked so good that night.
Meryl.
- I felt like Julia
Roberts in the like really
expensive clothing store.
(laughter)
When she pre...